boa noite
toda pessoa é uma escola
tem gente que acha que a escola é chata
e obviamente eu não vim aqui hoje dizer
pra vocês que toda pessoa é chata
toda pessoa é uma escola
toda pessoa é uma oportunidade de
aprendizado
o mundo de possibilidade uma forma única
de existir
toda pessoa é uma escola e por isso toda
pessoa é responsável por ensinar e
aprender
vocês acharam que venham aqui hoje
assistir palestra aplaudiam e ficar por
isso mesmo né não
eu vim aqui hoje o que eu quero passar
um dever de casa pra vocês um dever de
casa que vai durar a vida inteira já tem
um pessoal tremendo dilema quando eu saí
desse palco hoje eu quero que você se
lembre de que você é uma escola
eu falo isso porque eu acredito que todo
mundo tem um foguinho dentro de ser é
bem verdade que às vezes foguinho também
o chuchu
precisamos de um pouco de oxigênio
precisamos de um pouco de gás ou às
vezes um simples sopro é suficiente para
fazer esse foguinho se recompor porque
por mais que estudar seja chato para
algumas pessoas
aprender é legal e aprender faz esse
foguinho brilhar mais e mais e essa
relação com o outro que a gente aprende
eu vou pedir pra vocês por um instante
para pensar e um professor que tenha
sido importante na sua vida
pensaram provavelmente esse professor
que você pensou mas só porque ele te
ensinou a fórmula de bàscara ou porque
ele explicou sobre as ligações químicas
ou ainda porque ele te diz é a diferença
entre o advérbio adjunto adverbial será
que algum dia você aprendeu isso o fato
é que esse professor se conectou com
você e você lembra dele com carinho
esse professor provavelmente olhou pra
você e fez você acreditar mais em você
mesmo ou ele acreditou mais em você ou
simplesmente esse professor que ouviu ou
ainda esse professor de desafio e fez
você ser melhor e você lembra dele com
carinho por isso a ciência já explica
que a atividade está diretamente
relacionada ao aprendizado
as nossas conexões neurais
elas têm uma cola sabe qual é essa cola
é o afeto o afeto é a cola entre as
ligações neurais e quanto mais essas
ligações de moraes são feitas mais forte
elas ficam a ponto de elas nunca mais
serem feitas
e assim a gente aprende olha só que
interessante
nós seres humanos somos seres
relacionais gostamos de dar e receber
amor
gostamos de ouvir o outro gostamos de
gostamos de nos conectar com o outro ea
gente aprende assim então a gente sim é
responsável por fazer essa mágica do
aprendizado acontecer porque toda pessoa
é uma escola
é bem verdade que o nosso sistema
educacional acaba privilegiando mais a
matemática e as linguagens
ninguém está muito preocupado na escola
em quem a gente é o que a gente sente o
qual é a nossa real identidade
nosso sistema educacional está
preocupado muito mais com cérebro do que
o coração
de acordo com a unesco
uma pesquisa que eles fizeram com mais
de 500 pessoas de 57 países
num documento intitulado que toda
criança deve aprender
eles disseram algumas dimensões de
aprendizado o que toda criança deve
aprender uma dessas dimensões foi o
desenvolvimento emocional e social
então vamos combinar que está mais do
que na hora do nosso sistema educacional
o olhar para as crianças como um todo
olhar para as crianças como um ser
integral seres que sentem
eu quando eu escrevi um livro infantil
para ajudar as crianças e identificar em
suas emoções
foi muito engraçado porque eu recebi uma
avalanche de mensagens pelo twitter por
facebook por e-mail e todas as redes
sociais vocês possam imaginar
as pessoas queriam saber a bom eu já
entendi que é importante desenvolver
desenvolver o lado emocional e social
das crianças mas como eu faço isso
então eu decidi é criar uma metodologia
e eu vou apresentar aqui pra vocês
a metodologia é o âncora e é um acrônimo
eu apresento aqui pra vocês
cada uma das letras o adu ancoram é
acolher as emoções que é isso né
a gente cria um espaço seguro para que a
gente possa ouvir o outro para que o
outro possa falar sobre as suas emoções
pra gente
obviamente que não adianta a gente
esperar a criança querer ser honesta com
a gente com as suas emoções se a gente
mesmo não é honesto com a gente mesmo né
então aqui o acolher as emoções não é só
para a criança mas também pra gente
uma vez eu fui almoçar com um amigo meu
de trabalho
eu estava super a goleada numa fase da
minha vida que eu não sabia o que eu
queria fazer
ah
o mosquitinho da educação ainda não
tinha mordido e eu estava falando pra
ele não eu estou muito agoniada puxada
não sei o que fazer da minha vida ele
olhou pra mim e falou assim tônia tudo
bem tudo bem tudo bem nada não é você
que passa dias e noites pensando sobre
isso como insônia
depois daquele tudo bem fez muito
sentido para mim era a forma dele de
acolher as minhas emoções e é esse tudo
bem que eu quero que vocês levem doha de
acolher as emoções
o enem é nomear as emoções e aqui é
literalmente dizer nomear o que a gente
está sentindo muitas vezes a gente tem
dificuldade de expressar o que a gente
está sentindo né
eu mesma quando era um pouco mais nova
quando alguém perguntava como é que tá
lá tu me sentindo meio esquisita mas
esquisita não é emoção
ou então quando alguém pergunta para
você o que é que está tudo bem ou do mal
só que bem e mal não é emoção
então essa dificuldade que a gente tem
que se expressar é importante pro e
nomear as emoções e aqui só o fato da
gente dá nome ao que a gente está
sentindo já mostra que a gente tem
responsabilidade sobre isso e até ajuda
a dissipar um pouco essa energia de
emoção que às vezes vêm com uma
intensidade enorme os e do âncora é o
compreender compreendeu que compreender
causas e consequências
quais são as causas daquela emoção
o time fez sentir aquilo e as
consequências também porque a forma que
eu reajo a minha emoção também tem
impacto né
as emoções elas influenciam nossos
pensamentos que por sua vez influenciam
a forma que a gente se comporta
influencia o lugar que a gente está o
resultado daquilo então compreender as
consequências é muito importante para a
gente desenvolver empatia entender um
pouco mais do contexto social para que
eu posso reagir de toda e qualquer forma
em qualquer ambiente
que conseqüências isso tem então c é
compreender causas e conseqüências
o do âncora é organizar e dar
significado que é isso aqui basicamente
é encontrar padrões que já não foi
trocar o controle foi trocar o canal da
televisão enquanto uma criança estava
assistindo seu desenho animado favorito
alguém já tentou fazer isso não tem tem
não é uma boa idéia a criança
provavelmente vai reagir de uma forma
impulsiva e muito intensa porque ela
queria ver aquele desenho animado ou
então aquela mesma criança quando tiver
no seu quarto concentrada desenhando e
alguém num rompante um irmão chegar com
a bola uma energia diferente daquela
tava também vai ter aquele mesma reação
aquele mesmo grito de raiva por exemplo
e aqui é importante ajudar a criança a
compreender esse padrão dela entender
que quando ela se sente provavelmente
desrespeitada ou invadida ela tem de lá
aquele grito
isso ajuda a ela acendeu um sinal sem o
vermelho sinalzinho vermelho de que eu
já sei quando eu me sinto desrespeitada
eu já sei que vem um grito por aí
isso nos leva ao r de regular as emoções
esse sinal zinho vermelho ajuda a gente
a pensar
caramba eu já sei que eu vou dar aquele
grito será que faz sentido dar aquele
grito bom é muito mais fácil falar do
que fazer né então regular as emoções
é muito difícil não é simples mas esse é
um processo de aprendizado que a gente
começa desde pequeno e vai aprendendo ao
longo da vida
o sinal vermelho ajuda a gente a lembrar
que a gente pode escolher a forma que a
gente vai reagir aquela emoção
a psicologia infantil já entrou num
consenso de que as crianças que são
capazes de regular as suas emoções
elas tendem a prestar mais atenção elas
tendem a colocar mais esforço na tarefa
elas tendem a ter níveis menores de
estreia
se elas também tendem a conseguir mediar
conflitos e o interessante aqui que a
gente tem uma pegadinha regular as
emoções
é muito fácil colocar num slide
apresentar aqui pra vocês mas é muito
difícil a gente fazer isso
principalmente quando aquela emoção
intensa invadir o nosso corpo em nosso
cérebro ele não está completamente
formado quando a gente nasce ele
continua se desenvolvendo até mais ou
menos uns 25 anos ea parte do nosso
cérebro responsável justamente por
regular as emoções também está se
desenvolvendo
então eu peço paciência com as crianças
que vocês convivem porque eles vão sim
da oplit que eles dão no meio do
supermercado fazendo as mães morrerem de
vergonha porque biologicamente essas
crianças não estão prontas para regular
as emoções
eu tô dizendo de das crianças de todas
as idades está principalmente 20 aos 25
anos crianças de 25 também costumam dar
esse problema eo a do âncora é agir para
aprender que é o agir para aprender aqui
a gente traçar a estratégia para saber
lidar melhor com as nossas emoções
se você tem uma criança por exemplo você
pode fazer um cartão desse tipo quando o
choro é porque eu estou trecho eu
preciso de um abraço
tem criança que fala que precisa
desenhar que precisa ouvir a sua música
favorita ou ainda ela precisa ficar
sozinho pouco ou tomar um banho para
tristeza embora é esse que eu apresentei
para vocês foi o âncora e eu queria
contar pra vocês é que eu tenho um irmão
e meu irmão é dez anos mais novo do que
eu
quando a gente era pequeno eu estudava
numa escola particular na cidade
em tese era melhor escola da cidade eu
sempre fui muito cdf e tinha bolsa de
estudos lá
por outro lado o meu irmão estudava numa
escola pública
a minha família não tinha uma condição
financeira muito boa
e pra mim é muito difícil ver essa
contradição dentro da própria casa
eu em tese estudando na melhor escola da
cidade e ele na pior escola quando tinha
mais ou menos uns 14 anos e fez muito
sentido para mim e eu senti essa
responsabilidade muito grande minha
família decidiu então alugar a casa que
a gente morava
vamos morar com a minha avó ea gente
vende a roupa ea mãe começou a trabalhar
todo mundo fazer um pouquinho ea gente
conseguiu transferir meu irmão para uma
escola particular
meu irmão
estudou ea gente como família venceu ele
se formou no segundo grau quando ele se
formou no segundo grau eu tive uma
conversa com ele aquela conversa de
irmão mais velho né
eu lembro nitidamente dessa conversa e
eu espero que ele lembre também até hoje
eu falei pra ele
bem vindo ao mundo adulto na verdade eu
não sabia direito o que estava falando
mas o que eu disse para ele o que eu
quis dizer é que a partir daquele
momento ele ia seguir o seu caminho
sozinho eu estaria ali para apoiá lo e
ajudá lo sempre que fosse preciso para
as mães e pais que estão aqui me ouvindo
devem imaginar como isso é difícil
deixar o seu filho e sozinho
mesmo sabendo de todas as dores do
crescimento que ele vai passar
bom eu sempre tive uma relação maternal
com meu irmão então eu sempre tive isso
muito forte dentro de mim
acontece que eu continuava perguntando
pra ele
como é que tem como é que está a
faculdade que nota você tirou como assim
você faltou à aula
o interessante é que hoje
meu irmão está se aventurando em terras
estrangeiras e meu irmão não terminou a
faculdade
vocês não imaginam como uma pessoa que
fez mestrado em educação consegue
conviver com o irmão que não terminou a
faculdade
isso é muito difícil para mim e eu tive
que jogar minha âncora
eu tive que jogar minha âncora e
mergulhar em mim mesmo para entender o
que aquilo significava pra mim que eu
estava sentindo e eu tive que ter muita
coragem
a ge mesmo com o coração para poder dar
o espaço pra que ele voasse sozinho e
também tive que ter muito desprendimento
com o resultado o desapego mesmo porque
a gente não pode querer que o outro siga
o caminho ou cumprir as expectativas que
a gente quer
então tá em contato com as minhas
emoções foi muito importante pra poder
entender melhor o meu irmão poderia me
colocar no lugar dele e respeitar as
decisões dele entrar em contato com as
minhas emoções fez com que eu fosse
melhor indivíduo
eu acredito que os melhores indivíduos
se formam como melhores profissionais
que são melhores cidadãos e que vão
formar uma melhor sociedade já que a
gente é um ser social
vocês lembram que eu falei pra você que
toda pessoa é uma escola
então meu irmão é minha escola quem a
escola de vocês
e como você estão se saindo como escola
obrigada